hello and welcome to Rochford district
matters the magazine produced by the
council for its residents this is the
spring 2013 edition in this edition are
articles on forthcoming benefit changes
the elections on the second of May
action plans for hockley don't choke on
smoke making plastic fantastic keeping
up with the beat and much more that will
begin with community news a great place
to work with a strong track record of an
achievement an organization that punches
above its weight which has a strong
track record of innovation these are
just some of the phrases used by an
independent panel who recently reviewed
the way the council operates in November
2012 the council invited a team
comprising a leader chief executive and
specialist officers from other local
authorities to look at how the council
operates and offer feedback on how it
can improve the peer review team
conducted a series of interviews with
councillors staff residents and partners
in order to get their views on what the
council does well and what it could do
better in its report the review team
said the council has a strong and
effective senior management and
political leadership is a good partner
to work with including its role in the
joint area action plan for london
Southend Airport with Southend Borough
Council
has a strong track record of achievement
specifically in the areas of waste and
recycling rates and outsourcing there is
a full report on the website at www k
and accompanying this article is a very
nice picture although taken in the snow
of the chief executive of the council
poor Warren the Leader of the Council
Councillor Terry cut more and the head
of finance Yvonne would award and
they're holding on to that peer review
report and how you can help us to
continue to make a difference the
feedback we received from the peer
review team would not have been possible
without the contribution from our have
your say group and we're looking for
more people to join to date there are
around 500 people signed up to the group
it is made up of Rochford district
residents who volunteered to express
their views on the council's proposals
and local services the information
provided helps the council to make its
decisions the council seeks to involve
all members of the community to ensure
that the views expressed are as
representative as possible and we want
to expand it so more people can have
their say on our plans in order for us
to get the information we need you will
be asked to fill in questionnaires take
part in telephone surveys and
participate in focus groups when signing
up to take part in the group you will be
asked to highlight any particular areas
of interest this is to ensure your views
are taken into account when relevant
consultations come up
you will be approached to get involved
in consultations throughout the year you
don't have to respond every time we just
ask that you get involved at leat at
least once a year members are selected
to get involved according to the type of
consultation sometimes every member of
the group will be called upon sometimes
it may only be 20 people questionnaires
shouldn't take longer than 20 to 30
minutes but focus groups will take
longer the group gives you the chance to
express your opinions to the people that
make decisions you can help to represent
the views of the whole community by
bringing your ideas and viewpoints to
the group being part of the group will
be a valuable experience and is an
opportunity to give something back to
your community the consultation
exercises help the council to understand
what you think about the issues and as a
result can help to influence decision
making members of the group will receive
a regular newsletter explaining how
their views have helped in the
decision-making process how do I join
you can join via the website WWE govt UK
/a hy s sign up or telephone and ruling
community planning officer on 0170 231
8061 or email and glue dot lowing at
Rochford gov UK for more details
this month get down to the mill arts &
Events Center and Rayleigh for events
for younger audiences including a
magical puppet show called suitcase
circus plus the Essex Book Festival
events for children and first Laura
Dockrell introduces the wonderful world
of Darcy burdock this is on Saturday the
sixteenth of March at three-thirty p.m.
suitable for eight to eleven year olds
so why not meet the wild dark and
colorful brain of Laurel as it indulges
in the world of Darcy burdock Laura will
entertain the audience with readings of
Darcy's stories about the likelihood of
octopuses trying to kiss girls and human
pancakes weird wacky wonderful ticket
surprise 6-pound and you can vote by
calling a one two four five to six
double 748 the suitcase circus is a
theater and puppet show for children
aged 24 and over and their families this
heartwarming and interactive performance
features a lineup of extraordinary
talented performing objects all with
their own unique and captivating story
lines sukh a circus features the most
unlikely of performers including the
world's only acrobatic potato sack a
daredevil ski glove an incredible
dancing milkshake straw and the lovable
yet bizarre magical Mexican Hat timmreck
suitcase circus is on a Sunday the 17th
of March at two o'clock at tickets a
three-pound and you can book by calling
o 1 702
318 191 and on Saturday the first of
June it's wild woods day and you can
find out more by visiting w WH foods
guru K the winter weather didn't dampen
the spirits of more than 1,000 visitors
who flocked to clements for leisure
center in January for the council's free
family sports festival families with
children of all ages were treated to a
sports day extravaganza which included
badminton bokya climbing dance fencing
karate squash and swimming the family
sports festival was organized by the
council in partnership with virgin
active active Rochford an active
castlepoint more free sports events and
festivals are currently being planned so
check the website www Rockford Garvey UK
forward slash leisure to find out more
it's another packed year of exhibitions
at the windmill rarely windmill has
recently achieved the accreditation of
quality assured visitor attraction from
visit England this is the fourth year in
a row that the windmill has received
this recognition visit England is a
national body that assesses visitor
attractions throughout the country the
report praised the warm welcome offered
by the volunteers as well as their
enthusiasm and knowledge you can sample
the same warm welcome that the visit
England judges enjoyed when the windmill
reopens for 2013 on Saturday the
thirtieth of march through to and
including sep tember the team that looks
after the windmill has put together a
pack
program of special events for you to
visit and enjoy throughout the year
opening times are wednesdays from ten
a.m. to 1pm and saturdays and sundays
from 1pm to 4pm the windmill is also
hosting various exhibitions including
community service volunteers healthy
aging and project Raley month a local
artist who will be painting at the venue
a photographic exhibition dedicated to
the creativity of deaf young people and
sales in the wind celebrating the
windmills 200th anniversary there's more
information available on the website
including dates when the windmill is
closed for private functions I'll give
you that address in a moment entry is
free of charge but donations are welcome
and this is actually a call for
volunteers you see the windmill wouldn't
be as successful or popular as it is
today without the support and generosity
of its volunteers and they're always
looking for more people to become
involved in the windmill so for more
information on events at the windmill
and details on how to get involved in
volunteering at the windmill please
contact the leisure team on Oh 17025 463
double 6 you could email if you like
leisure at Rockford dot-gov dot uk' and
of course don't forget the website www k
forward slash wings
your council tax explained the total
average council tax for Rochford
residents were increased by northpoint
seven percent for the financial year
april 2013 to march 2014 rochford
district council has frozen council tax
for the last two years after careful
consideration of the financial impact of
freezing again the district council has
been luck tantly agreed to an increase
in our share of the council tax taking
our band d 2 205 pounds 11 p an increase
of about 8p per week as its county
council and the Essex Fire and Rescue
Authority have frozen their parts of the
overall tax bill the new police and
crime Commissioner for Essex has set an
increase of four pounds 77 and the
parish and town councils have increased
by an average of one pound 96 this means
that the total average council tax bill
for a band d property will be 1530 8090
1p per annum an overall average increase
of 10 pounds 69 per annum of your total
council tax bill only thirteen percent
comes to Rochford District Council with
the rest going to Essex County Council
71 percent Essex Fire and Rescue
Authority four percent police and crime
Commissioner for Essex nine percent and
the parish and town councils three
percent for further information see the
booklet which accompanies your council
tax bill or visit our website whv govt
UK
how the council's services are funded
the council receives money from
government grant including money tools
the cost of benefits paid out income
from fees and charges such as parking
charges and the money collected from
council tax for 2013-14 the amounts are
government grant including benefits
subsidy 20 2.1 million fees and charges
4.7 million and council tax 5.9 million
the local government finance settlement
figures were finalized on Monday the
fourth FEHB 2013 and continue to reflect
the unprecedented economic circumstances
Roger district councils grant was
reduced by 16.2 percent in 2011-12 and
reduced by a further 11.1 percent in
2012-13 the total grant awarded for
2013-14 has reduced by a further four
hundred and eighty-three thousand pounds
or 13.5 percent this is offset in part
by the increase in new homes bonus
representing an overall reduction of 308
thousand pounds or eight percent the
total grant including new Harlem's bonus
awarded for 2013-14 is 3.5 two million
pounds to put this into perspective
delivery of statutory services alone is
estimated to cost approximately nine
point six million pounds the budget gap
for 2013-14 has been met by increasing
Council text by one point nine to seven
percent 8p per week for AB and E
property reducing the amount spent on
verge cutting changing the way the
council manages its parks open spaces
and play areas
expanding the sale of logs and firewood
revising the charge framework for
collection of bulky waste the corporate
plan in the corporate planner counselor
identifies how it aims to continue to
improve its services to local
communities as well as enhancing the
difference it makes to the local economy
and environment over the next few years
the council will focus on wealth
creation in the district supporting
economic growth and job creation the
provision of housing in the district and
continue to deliver efficiency savings
against the backdrop of continuing cuts
in local government funding
get ready for big changes rochford
District Council's local council tax
support or L cts-v will come into effect
from the first of April and we want
residents who will be affected to be
prepared for the changes from the first
of April this year council tax benefit
or CTB will be abolished and replaced by
the l cts scheme around 2,300 working
age residents in the rupture district
will be affected by the changes under
the current arrangements the council
receives funding from the government to
cover its costs this will not be the
case of the new scheme under the El CTS
arrangements the government will give
the council of fixed grant this will be
ten percent less than we currently pay
out meaning we have five hundred and
twenty thousand pounds less to run the
new scheme we've had to make some very
difficult decisions because pensioners
are protected the level of support given
to working age customers under the El
CTS scheme will have to be less that it
is under the current scheme however over
the last three months since the scheme
was agreed the revenues and benefits
team has been working closely with the
Citizens Advice Bureau to try and help
as many people as possible to be
financially prepared for the changes we
will now tell you how you can find out
what the changes are what they mean and
how to access vital help and support
that is available to you please don't
leave it until it's too late these
changes are coming and you must be
prepared
lct s only affects working age claimants
and the main points of the scheme are
people living in properties whose
council tax band is e f g or h will have
their LC TS restricted to the maximum
amount payable for a band d property
regardless of their financial
circumstances every working age claimant
will pay the first twenty percent of
their council tax liability this means
people who currently get full CTB will
have to pay something towards their
council tax from April the first the
savings limit for claiming LC TS will be
six thousand pound the limit for CTB at
present is 16,000 pound child
maintenance is currently disregarded in
full when we calculate CTB this
disregard will stop and we will take
Child Maintenance into account as income
when we calculate entitlement to LC TS
currently we reduce CTB for working-age
people if an adult friend or relative
lives with them non dependents we want
to try any some of the financial
pressure as well as try to reduce
homelessness and under occupation of
houses therefore we will stop making
non-dependent deductions when we
calculate entitlement to LC TS set an
adult rebate can be granted two single
people who have a high income if they
share their home with someone who is on
a low income not their partner this
scheme will be stopped for working-age
claims
since the local council tax support was
agreed by the council the council's
revenues and benefits team have worked
hard to ensure that those affected have
been given access to the help they need
in January the team wrote to all those
affected to let them know about the
changes and encourage them to visit the
Citizens Advice Bureau for help with
financial planning these letters also
included a sample bill giving an
estimate of what the amount that will
have to be paid would be in February the
team also employed a contractor to
conduct home visits to those who have
never had to pay council tax before so
they could get access to help on their
doorsteps if you are working age
currently in receipt of council tax
benefit and you haven't heard about the
changes yet then contact for councils
revenues and benefits team on 0 1 702 31
8 197 or 318 198 to discuss your
circumstances and the support that's on
offer alternatively the council is
working closely with the CA B and you
can access their services details of
which we will give you in a moment as
well as the council and the CA be there
are other avenues you can explore if
you're looking to return to work
for example you can visit the
government's website www k /o obser and
register for their services including
job searching in your area if you don't
have access to the internet don't forget
that you can access it free in your
local library council tax calculator
residents can log on to our website and
use our calculator to see if they may be
entitled to claim council tax support
existing working age claimants of
council tax benefit will automatically
be transferred to the new system to use
the calculator visit www k and follow
the links if you still haven't made a
financial plan for the changes then
don't worry there is still time you can
either call the council's revenues and
benefits team on 0170 2318 197 or 318
198 or get in touch with the Rockford
and rayleigh Citizens Advice Bureau or
the ca be as it's known it offers free
face-to-face and telephone advice and is
open throughout the week at two
different locations the rockford office
you'll find in baclayon Rochford the
postal code there is SS for 1a why it's
open on Tuesday from ten a.m. to two
p.m. and on Thursday at the same time
the Rayleigh office is situated at the
Civic sweet hot clear Odin rayleigh and
the postal code there is SS 680 be there
open on mondays thursdays and fridays
from ten in the morning to two in the
afternoon you could pull them on 0844
for double 70 80 8 or you can access
their website w WH foods CA B or one
word org dot uk' advisors are available
to deal with any issues that those
affected may have and are also able to
offer advice on maximizing income to
prevent any financial hardship that may
be experienced under the new scheme the
online guidance about the changes to
council tax benefits is available at WWF
UK /l c t SC and www.vitac.com get free
access to the internet in your local
library now there are some other reforms
on the way from the first of april this
year
the under occupation rule in the social
rented sector restrictions will apply to
council and housing association tenants
living in houses larger than they need a
fourteen percent reduction in housing
benefit will apply if tenants are under
occupying by one bedroom and a
twenty-five percent reduction in housing
benefit will apply if they are under
occupying by two or more bedrooms this
will only affect people of working age
who receive help to pay their rent and
the disability living allowance or the
DLA as we know it is to be replaced it's
going to be replaced with a new benefit
called personal independent payment and
here's a little thing you're not going
to forget you abbreviate that to pip
this will involve the introduction of
revised assessment criteria to decide
who is eligible pip will be used for all
new claimants and all existing DLA
working age claimants will be reassessed
you can keep up to date with all the
changes WWE are a govt UK forward slash
benefits forward slash changes hyphen
benefit and I will reiterate please
don't forget pensioners are not affected
by this local council tax support scheme
it will affect only those residents who
are of working age
out and about dates for your diary the
rock / District Council leisure team has
lots of events and activities planned
for 2013 some of the P dates are marched
October walking your way to the games
21st of March active 50-plus festival in
Lilith to the 12th of May mills open
weekend the 17th of April to the
twenty-second of May time for life
50-plus exercise and life skills the
first of June wildwoods de jeune
generally watch the district sports
festival july to august sx urban games
fourteenth and fifteenth of sep tember
rayleigh arts festival 19th for the 28th
of sep tember Rochford art trail
September to December children's theatre
at the mill arts & Events Center for
full details on these events please
contact the leisure team by phone Oh
17025 463 double six email leisure at
Rochford gavage ok all look at the
websites www k all events and dates are
subject to change that are correct at
time of this recording
clubs and groups the yoga Club held on
tuesday and wednesday evenings 7 30 29
p.m. at the Scout Hall Magnolia road
hawk wall community-based mixed ability
classes they cost five pounds 25 per
session and for this you can contact
chris dot findley be IM dl e y at bt
internet com the roach art group hold
meetings on wednesday evenings between 7
30 and nine thirty p.m. at theresa's
church hall ashington road Rochford ss4
1rf located to the rear of the church
there is good lighting and facilities
all abilities are catered for at this
friendly club who is a variety of media
membership inquiries of welcome
reasonable fees apply for this group
contact christine on 0 1 702 586 336 or
john on 079 double 3263 930 the
Horticultural Society at hopland
district have reopened their trading hut
on Sunday mornings between 10am and 12
noon it's open every Sunday morning
until Sunday the 27th of October the Hut
is located behind corporal village hall
with free parking and you can get
compost grow bags and all sorts of
fertilizers as well as friendly advice
on various aspects of gardening
membership is three pound per family per
year
and for some great days out there is a
tour of fowl nurse island if you'd like
to view the wonderful wildlife of
fairness well here's your chance a
guided tour on a tractor trailer of this
fascinating part of our district will
take place on wednesday the 12th of june
or wednesday the 26th of jun 2013 from
630pm limited spaces are available book
early to avoid disappointment and
tickets cost 16 pounds per person the
further information please contact julia
mitchell Oh 17 and 23 181 and double for
or email julia dot mitchell at Rochford
gulf qk canoodle village day enjoy the
day out in collusion with plenty for
everyone to enjoy this is on saturday
18th of may 12 p.m. to 5pm sir nicholas
church will be open with tower tools
cream teas are various stalls in the
grounds there will be family fun
activities including a bouncy castle and
penalty shootout game the school will be
open for guided tours a car boot sale
don't adjel tea and refreshments the
village hall has a vintage tractor
display quad bikes ploughman's lunches
and belly dancers there will also be a
shuttle bus to the marina and wetlands
at wallasey during the afternoon
I'm ready mounts program for this year
starts with 12 nite by William
Shakespeare which is on the twenty first
of June at 7pm then there's the merry
wives of windsor by William Shakespeare
on 13 and the 14th of july at 3pm the
children's play finding alice is on the
seventeenth of all vista 2pm and Lady
Windermere's Fan by Oscar Wilde on the
seventeenth of August at 5pm if you're
coming along please bring your own rugs
or chairs and pay at the gate
refreshments are available for more
information you can contact mike stone
on Oh 1268 double seven of 53 28 and now
the council committee and community
forum dates all meetings will take place
at the Civic sweet too hot we rode
rayleigh SS 680 be starting at seven
thirty p.m. unless stated otherwise the
development committee 21st of march
audit committee 26th of march standards
committee 11th of april the review
committee 16th of april the executive
the 17th of april development committee
18th of april the council 23rd of april
annual council twenty first of May
for information contact to contact
members services on 0 1 702 318 141 a
Stanbridge Memorial Hall is now open and
available to hire from a 30 pound per
session and you can book morning
afternoon evening or all day seven days
a week this is suitable for various
functions including parties clubs
classes etc for more information visit
www are checked before going to press
they are subject to change we recommend
you visit our website www k or contact
the organizers to check before going to
an event rayleigh based charity hope
works is seeing what's what wa TT after
being awarded more than 1,000 pounds
from Rochford housing associations
Maureen's Gift Fund thanks to the
funding the furniture charity has
purchased specialist electrical testing
equipment to help ensure that each item
donated is fit for use the charity's one
of the number of community groups across
the rotifer district to benefit from
Maureen's gift set up in 2009 the scheme
supports charities resident groups and
voluntary organisations in need of funds
to help deliver activities within the
local community established in June 2012
hope works provides low-cost furniture
and electrical goods to local people in
need the charity also offers items at a
further reduced cost to people in crisis
who have been referred to the project by
a partner agency richard fox from hope
works said we want to thank Rochford
housing for granting us the funding
needed to purchase a portable appliance
without this equipment we would not be
able to accept electrical goods which
will then end up in landfill this
machine safeguards our clients as well
as protecting our environment if you're
involved with a local community group
and could do with a cash boost Maureen's
gift may be able to help with a share of
5,000 pounds for local projects there
are two rounds for applications 30th of
june and the 31st of december half the
fund is shared between successful
applicants after half after round 1 the
other half after round two for an
application pack contact rockford
housing on Oh 300 1 2 3 35 14 or a 800
oh 12 1991 or you can email contact us
at sanctuary dash housing co uk and
quote Maureen's gift elections for Essex
County Council are due to take place on
the second of May this year there are
five county council electoral areas
within the Rockford district these areas
are known as divisions and one
councillor represents each area the five
divisions in Rockford district are
rarely north and Rayleigh South Rockford
North Montford south and Rockford West
it's important to remember that these
elections are for the county council
which has different responsibilities to
the district council essex county
council is responsible for a number of
services in the area and a full list is
available at WWDC OV UK you must
register to vote by the 17th of april
2013 this is also the deadline for
applying for a postal vote registering
to vote gives you a chance to elect your
county council representatives and have
your say about how the county council is
run voting is your opportunity to make a
difference to the issues that are
important to you and the community and
if you don't register you're not to be
able to vote in the upcoming elections
now if you'd like more information on
this year's elections and how to
register to vote or to apply for a
postal vote you can visit WWF a govt UK
forward slash elections application
forms can be downloaded from the
council's website at www Rockford gov't
UK or you can contact the election of
this helpline by telephone on 0 1 702
318 187 have you ever thought of an
election alarm clock well you can in
fact get one by signing up to the free
service called the election alarm clock
and this is a convenient way to keep up
to date with all the information
regarding up
elections by signing up to that alarm
clock you will be alerted to upcoming
elections when and how to register for
elections when and how you can vote and
where you can vote and if you want to
sign up for this service you can do it
at WWE r OTA govt UK /a election alarm
clock you can then fill in your details
as requested and click Submit and that's
it once you've done this you will start
to receive election alerts you will say
on action plans after a great deal of
community consultation over the last few
years for both the rockford area action
plan and the rayleigh area action plan
the final consultation drafts are being
produced the two planning documents will
be available for you to view and make
comments on in the early summer we would
really appreciate it if you could spare
time to let us know whether you agree
with the proposed final plans or not the
rainy plan and Rochford plans set out
the vision and policies for the future
development of the two town centres the
two area action plans need to go through
the formal adoption process to become
development planning documents in the
local development framework and inform
future planning applications in the town
centres if you want to find out more you
can stay in touch in the following ways
check the website w WAW k email your
preferred contact details to planning
dot policy at Rochford UK or telephone
0170 2 3 18 19 1
hockley area action plan answers to your
questions we've been asking lots of
questions about the hotly area action
plan or have to try make things easier
we've answered some of the most
frequently asked ones is the AAP
proposing a large supermarket for
hockley if so why one of the common
misconceptions with the Hat is that it
will encourage development of a large
supermarket in hot p center on the
contrary the Hat proposes that the
current policy that restricts
development on elden way to industrial
use be replaced with one that permits
retail development within a dedicated
area of Elden way provided a number of
criteria are met one criteria includes
that if a food store is proposed it will
only be permitted if it's no bigger than
3,000 square meters it's the council
redeveloping a hot p center if so why
the council is not proposing to
undertake redevelopment of hot p center
and doesn't own land to which policies
in the Hat relate the purpose of the Hat
is to ensure there is a plan in place
with which to guide development brought
forward by others as part of the normal
development process why does the hap
proposed housing for the center of
hockley
government requires the council to
identify in the land where housing can
be built in the district in order to
accommodate this housing the council has
had to allocate greenfield sites for
development but it's important that
brownfield sites are used where possible
previous public consultation has
identified that most people would prefer
brownfield sites to be developed for
housing ahead of greenfield sites
housing in the center of hot clay would
also be well located in relation to the
train station shops and services and so
helping support local businesses and
services and reducing reliance on the
private car however we are also aware
that many people are concerned about
there being too much housing in the
center of hockley as such the Hat does
not propose as many drawings are
permitted as previous studies have
suggested would be possible why is there
no detailed transport assessment with
the hat there's no detailed transport
assessment with the hat for several
reasons the hab does not set out
predetermined improvements to be made in
hockley because improvements including
those made to the transport
infrastructure will depend on the type
of development that's proposed policy
three of the hat states that all
development proposals should either
incorporate or contribute to all schemes
identified within the plan this includes
the improvements to the transport
network this will ensure that
improvements to the public realm are
integrated with the development proposal
and won't be hampered by them
as the weather gets warmer many of us
will be looking forward to getting
outdoors making more use of the garden
and opening the windows to let some
fresh air in its during this time that
the council's environmental health
department receives a number of
inquiries about the law on having a
bonfire as well as complaints about
smoke from bon fires bonfires connected
with trade or business waste are illegal
some exemptions apply this can include
the burning of waste from property
renovation or landscaping particularly
if it's carried out by a builder or
contractor if you're in a business or
trade premises and you produce dark
smoke or you show an intention to burn
items that would give off dark smoke
this is an offence and you can be
prosecuted where the items were burnt or
not if you're in a domestic property and
are thinking about having a bonfire our
advice would always be not to burn the
waste but recycle it instead there are
many ways to dispose of waste from
curbside recycling use of the recycling
centers for household waste composting
and via donations to charitable
organizations more information on how to
get rid of your waste through recycling
or reuse is provided on the council's
website to find out more visit www.a
govt UK /recycling or call our Customer
Services team on 0170 2318 one double
one
now it's nearly impossible to have a
bonfire without causing a problem with
smoke for your neighbors especially if
you live in a built-up area if smoke
from your bonfire causes a statutory
smoke nuisance we can issue an abatement
notice if the notice is not complied
with you could be fined on conviction up
to 5,000 pounds for domestic premises if
you're in a domestic property and decide
that you have no other alternative but
to have a bonfire we recommend you
consider your neighbors tell your
neighbors that you want to have a
bonfire and when you're going to have it
choose a day when neighbors or nearby
residents don't have their washing out
or their windows open always look at the
wind direction and weather conditions
don't burn damp material as this
produces lots of smoke don't burn
plastics rubber or materials such as
coated wood or carpets these materials
give off nasty toxic fumes and never
leave a bonfire unattended if you're
experiencing problems with smoke from
our neighbors bonfire we would advise
you to politely approach your neighbor
and tell them that it's a problem so
they have the opportunity to resolve the
matter if there is no improvement you
can make a complaint class we will need
your address and the address of where
the bonfires are taking place that your
details will remain confidential for
more information and visit www.got UK
forward slash bonfires or contact 0170
2318 one double one
we get a lot of calls asking us which
plastics can be put in the recyclables
bin although there are often recycling
instructions on the side of plastic
packaging each local authority has a
different scheme so what may be correct
in one area might not be correct for the
Rockford district council maximize
recycling scheme there are lots of
different types of plastics that you can
recycle in your curbside recyclables bin
so here's a handy little died which we
hope helps you to understand which
plastics you can put in that gray
recyclables thin you can put plastic
bottles yoghurt pots marjorine pots
plastic food trays plastic punnets
plastic sandwich container and plastic
carrier bags
unfortunately any items that are not
recyclable must be disposed of in your
purple lidded non-recyclables bin which
is sent to landfill and for that we mean
black or any other large plastic sacks
plastic film or plastic wrapping crisp
sweet and biscuit wrappers polystyrene
plastic bubble wrap plastic food pouches
plastic toys plastic plant pots even
plastic furniture and please note that
we can refuse to take your recyclables
or compostable spin if it contains items
which shouldn't be in there if you'd
like some more information on what can
and cannot be recycled please visit www
k /m recycling or you could crawl
customer services on 0170 2318 double 11
don't forget we also have a handy at a
glance recycling a to Zed that you can
use that's available at www k /recycling
a to
said have your electricals lost their
spark you are among the best in a
country when it comes to recycling and
we know you are enthusiastic about
making sure items such as plastic
bottles cans food and garden waste are
recycled but what about unwanted waste
electrical items such as phones Mobile's
hair dryers and radios if they're broken
or unwanted do you hang on to them
because it feels wrong to bend them
maybe you leave them to gather dust in
an off door cupboard or do you just
throw them in your bin did you know that
you can now recycle small items of waste
electrical and electronic equipment
known as we at all of the blue lmv
clothing banks located at 12 sites
around Rochford district items can also
be taken to the small we recycling bank
in the back lane car park rochford or to
the castle road recycling center
rayleigh we is required by EU law to be
treated correctly when discarded as
waste which means that no explore
electronic equipment should be disposed
of in any of your curbside bins please
note the recycling banks are for small
electricals only if you have any larger
items such as televisions or washing
machines please recycle them at the
castle road recycling center rayleigh or
book a bulky collection through Rochford
district council by calling customer
services on 0170 2318 one double one
small electrical items that can be
recycled include electronic devices
phones mobile phones printers remote
controls charges radios VCRs digit boxes
speakers hifi units electronic toys etc
electronic personal care hair dryers
hair straighteners electric toothbrushes
hair trimmers shavers hair curlers
facial saunas etc electrical appliances
are kettles toasters blenders sandwich
toasters earns coffee machines whisks
bread makers electric scales smoothie
makers etc and DIY and garden
electricals such as drills and power
tools so where to recycle your small
electrical appliances great wakering
Sports Center freight house car park in
rockford Roura the playing fields in
roar of lane Railly can you Dan village
hall Clements all sports center in Hawk
well golden cross parade ashington
ashington playing fields foul nest
village hall hopfully woods in hockley
hotkey library and the south end road
hockley fairview playing fields in
victoria road rayleigh and the royal oak
pub in Stanbridge so what happens next
once you've taken your small items to
the banks or recycling center its
collected and taken to a registered
treatment facility
Packaging external cables and had a set
of materials such as batteries
capacitors and oil are removed larger
items are taken apart by hand before
being shredded with smaller items the
shredded materials are mechanically
sorted to separate different types of
metal and plastics and over ninety seven
percent of the materials can then be
recycled into new items to be used in
your new hair dryer or power drill
please remember if your item is still in
good working order it can be reused this
should always be your first option visit
www k for local reuse outlets and keep
an eye out for we events coming up where
you might meet the dinosaur made
entirely from recycled materials your
perfect party venue whether it's your
sweet 16 or life about to start at 40
the freight house and the mill Arts &
Events Center are perfect for parties
whether you're celebrating your
engagement a special anniversary a
retirement party or a family
get-together whatever the occasion these
venues are the ideal settings for your
special events and with individual
suites and fully licensed bars your
event can accommodate between 30 to five
hundred guests whatever the occasion
from wedding receptions to family
parties or special birthday celebrations
the teams at the venue will help
organize everything to ensure your party
is unique and memorable and as a special
incentive to really get your party going
both then freight house and the mill
Arts & Events Center will give you
twenty-five percent of room hire for any
booking before the thirtieth of april
2013 to take advantage of this special
offer called the freight house on 0 1
702 548 977 or the mill arts & Events
Center on 01 268 double seven eight one
seven one and quote our DM
for further information please visit the
websites www the freight house code up
the UK and wwm ill haul co uk live
happily ever acted at your local leisure
centres thanks to the unique partnership
between virgin active health clubs and
Rochford district council you'll enjoy
all the luxuries of a health club plus
all the sports and activities you could
ever ask for in a Leisure Centre when
you visit Clements hall and really
leisure centres anyone can come along
and enjoy the fantastic sporting
facilities on a flexible pay and pay
basis or really save money by taking out
one of the no commitment virgin active
health and fitness monthly memberships
clements Hall Leisure Centre features a
25 metre swimming pool with separate
teaching pool and swim sessions which
are tailored to suit all from the
children learning their first strokes to
grandparents wanting to get some gentle
exercise or brush up on their butterfly
skills afterwards you can relax and
unwind in the poolside sauna steam room
and sparkle sports facilities at
clements hall and rayleigh leisure
centres include badminton squash and
tennis courts outside astroturf pitches
and even an indoor climbing wall at
clements hall and an impressive indoor
bowls arena with four rinks at Raley
Leisure Centre there's also a huge
variety of enrollment sports courses on
offer
and pay and play sessions for all ages
including active life for the over-50s
badminton basketball climbing urban
dance judo trampolining and the hugely
successful swim school the gyms are
equipped with all the latest technology
cardio and resistance equipment as well
as the newest innovations and
revolutionary equipment like kettlebells
Power Plate and VIP r plus those centers
provide a packed timetable of studio
exercise classes from group cycle to
electrifying zum the dance classes and
the new puma faas class which is based
on training methods adopted by the
world's elite athletes there really is
something for everyone what's more
Clements hall and Rayleigh leisure
centres provide the highest standard of
child care for kids from six weeks up to
eight years of age in Ofsted registered
freshers you can relax in the knowledge
your little ones are safe and don't
forget doors are open to anyone on a pay
and play basis but you'll save money if
you become a virgin active member for
more information please call Clements
Hall Leisure Centre on 0170 220 double 7
double 7 or the rayleigh Leisure Centre
on 0 1 2 6 8 6 5 4 5 10 please note the
facilities differ between locations
for a safer district keeping up with the
beat partnership efforts to tackle crime
and disorder in the district have been
taken to a new level with the
introduction of closer working
arrangements between the local
neighbourhood policing team and their
Community Safety colleagues from the
council in a pilot project neighborhood
police officers will have the use of a
hot desk within the community safety
department at the council's offices in
South Street the facility will be
available to neighborhood watch
constable PC Michel rawson and police
community support officer andrew hill
when on duty in the town during the week
though there will be no front desk
facility for the offer officers to meet
the public or for residents to report
incidents the availability of desk space
and other facilities will allow officers
to spend more time out on the street the
council's portfolio holder for the
community safety and chair of the castle
point and disrupt for District Community
Safety Partnership councillor Joe
McPherson said this will further develop
closer partnership working between local
police and our community safety team in
identifying and addressing emerging
priorities particularly with regard to
antisocial behavior as well as crime
label the police in inspector Jeff
Appleby added we're grateful to the
council for the offer of this facility
and appreciate the opportunity it gives
to increase our visible presence in the
town and surrounding area officers will
not be based at the council for the
duration of their shift but out and
about dealing with the issues that our
concern to residents such as nuisance
behavior and criminal damage
and the new police commissioner visits
really the recently elected police and
crime Commissioner or PCC for Essex Nick
Alston has called for a united community
effort to combat crime and users
behavior across the district on a recent
visit to raly he told Rochford district
matters I very much believe that local
problems need local solutions I see a
key part of my role is encouraging key
agencies such as the police the council
castle point and Rochford district
Community Safety Partnership source e SP
and the voluntary sector to work very
closely together to implement practical
measures to tackle crime and anti-social
behavior mr. Olson was elected to the
new role last November the son of a
former Deputy Chief Constable of Essex
his career has focused on public safety
and security and he has been involved in
shaping major changes in policing
arrangements in Britain and Northern
Ireland he said I intend to use my
experience and knowledge to help steer
Essex Police through the major changes
the false faces residents will have an
opportunity to discuss crime and
policing issues with the police and
crime Commissioner at a community
engagement meeting arranged in
conjunction with the castle point and
watch the district Community Safety
Partnership and the meeting will be held
on Thursday March the 28th from 6 30 to
8 30 p.m. details of the venue will be
published on Rochford district councils
website so go to ww our govt UK and via
the local media shortly
and a hate crime poster winner drawing
attention to the divisive issue of hate
crime 1 14 year-old Lily Scott a pupil
at Raley fits why I'm arts school a 50
pound amazon voucher from the Rochford
district hate crime panel her idea for a
poster promoting tolerance took first
place in a design competition organized
by the panel and supported by the CSP
the panel has been set up to promote
awareness of hate crime and works with
organizations and community groups to
change people's attitude to others the
poster competition was open to seniors
school pupils across the district and
was designed to encourage young people
to think about hate crime and how
victims must be encouraged to come
forward and report incidents rod hood
district matters is designed and
published by Rochford District Council
its editor is Patrick John the telephone
number for the council is 0 1 702 546
366 the magazine is printed by Morton
print--limited 01 50 75 2 3 4 5 6 and
this recording has been produced by
volunteers from the rayleigh Rochford
and castle point talking newspaper for
the blind